there is nobody that grew up with a
perfect family
none of us do sometimes you look at the
kid like oh look at that kid man he's
so lucky you know mom and dad christians
and they live in a 10 million dollar
home and they got nice cars and look at
the mom and dad and all this other stuff
you have no idea that dad's got a
cocaine addiction you have no idea the
mom and dad fighter you have no idea
that
they don't even sleep on the same but
you don't know everyone's drama but
everyone's got some kind of drama so i
think one of the things that helped me
is the following
when i would look at my uh uh lack of
in an area of my life and i said oh my
gosh but man my parents got a divorce oh
my gosh but i'm a one pointed gpa oh my
gosh look at me you know
i'm from iran nobody wants to buy
insurance from you you know guy that's
iranian when 9 11 just happened
i would hear all that stuff that your
fee i'm feeding myself right
i had one rule i followed listen if you
can talk
if you can walk if you can see if you
can hear
if you can taste if you can smell if you
speak a language if your mind works
and you can do enough of that you can do
whatever you want to do in your life
period i don't need a an alibi
i don't need an excuse so for some
people that is a father for some it's a
mother
for some it's abuse for some it's
parents that were there but hardcore
abuse
which is sometimes worse than not having
a father because if there's hardcore
abuse that abuse can go to a lot of
different levels right
so you know sitting there and wondering
about what we
lacked and all this other stuff um you
know almost
always for the rest of your life you
will always use
an alibi with that i had a guy that told
me he said
messaging him right now and he says well
you know you don't understand what's oh
for example perfect example to give you
we have two events going on this week
okay uh one is in dallas one is in
louisville
both of them are expected to have two to
four thousand people at their events
okay
dallas and louisville now watch this
dallas weather has a bad storm
so dallas is going to be in the 20s to
40s
this week dallas is going to be one
degree on monday
one degree when i lived in dallas five
years we never have one degree
the other team's going to louisville
louisville's conditions are also bad
so i just did a zoom today and guess
what i said i said guys this is the week
to see who's going to make the least
amount of excuses
both of you are going to bad weather
conditions both of you
but just like in sports when they say
that other team
knows how to play in the cold weather
they're going to win we're about to find
out which one of you guys can win
in cold weather and still make it happen
right okay
which means what well but you don't
understand the weather is cold but you
don't understand airports but you don't
understand what you don't understand you
can say but you don't understand for the
rest of your life with mom
dad girlfriend money all this other
stuff but what you don't understand
is you get to choose what you do and how
you handle that moving forward so
i'm not a big fan of alibis i always put
the pressure back on the person to say
at the end of the day if you can you
know small walk talk all that other
stuff
you can go out and do whatever you want
to do with your life